[MUSIC]
>> We will, we will rock you, rock you!
>> Today we are participating
in the executive challenge,
we'll participate in a series of role
plays and hopefully bring home the trophy.
>> I'm really excited to kind of take
our learnings and put it in action.
>> The entire quarter has been about
what kind of a leader I want to be and
why should someone follow me?
So I think mostly the prep was just
thinking through what I have learned and
what are the things that
I want to try today and
there can be a better way to get likes and
really expert feedback from alums and
people who will be judging the event.
And hopefully, that will play a big role
in how I shape out to be as a leader.
>> So how do you think your
team's going to do, today?
>> We're going to nail it, completely.
>> I think we've worked really
well together all quarter long, so
we're feeling pretty
confident about today.
>> We actually spent significantly more
time preparing the cases as a judge.
It's the executive challenge
than I ever did for
any case in my two years
of business school.
>> We're having fun today, this is
supposed to be a really great day for
all of us to come together,
so we're really excited.
[LAUGH]
>> I'm hoping that they'll come together
as a squad, and essentially treat this
day as us as a unit, against the world,
or essentially getting them ready for
this type of stuff in the real world.
>> I think it comes very close to
real life situations that's why
I love coming down here and
participate in it.
And it's almost a learning experience for
myself as well.
>> I think the biggest struggles in
becoming up with creative solutions but
luckily the team is really diverse so I
think we'll overcome that challenge today.
>> I hope to bring this idea
that sometimes just being candid
keeping things simple and understanding
the relationships that exist in the world.
You know, who's making the decisions,
how the decisions are being made, and
what the purpose of the meeting is.
>> And the way it goes, I think
we would be happy because their going to
get feedback it's going to help us grow.
Like they always say, this environment
is a safe environment and we
should be free to be vulnerable and
get change.
So I'm going to be happy because
I know it's for my good so
it going to have a happy end.
>> If we had to go back and
reapply to the GSPI I don't think we can
make it the talent is off the charts.
>> We are out here
representing Squad 68 and
we're ready to take the bull by the horns
today for the executive challenge.
>> Big 68!
Big 68!
>> We are very nervous but
at the same time we're very
excited to challenge ourselves.
You know,
get out from our comfort zone let's go 45!
>> One, two, three.
[LAUGH]
>> I think our preparation was on point.
>> Yeah, it's kind of too bad that we
can't actually go and implement this idea
now because we actually really thought we
had a cool idea and it's strange to get so
involved in it for 20 minutes and
then have it disappear so quickly.
>> I've sit in meeting like this for
the last 25 years
>> And, you know,
they have outperformed even some of the
people that we've had as mature managers.
>> I was actively trying to make sure
we both had equal air time because,
we had slightly different roles and
different priorities.
But, I thought that actually
worked out well for us.
>> Yeah, and given that there was so much
information, it was helpful to know that
Jacqueline had the technology covered and
I knew this is more money.
[LAUGH]
>> More about the business side.
>> Exactly, yeah,
we both talked about money.
>> Yeah.
>> It was great.
>> You really see a wide spectrum
of people flexing skills and
had a couple groups almost come
close to cracking the case.
But in any event, as a judge,
it's a great chance to interact and
Get back close with the university.
>> It was amazing, an amazing experience.
The judges were incredible, the feedback
that they gave was super relevant.
It built upon things that maybe we'd
already heard during the quarter, but
also some new perspectives as well.
So it was very, very helpful.
>> What they came in with was
a lot of insightful questions,
things that we were trying to predict.
Before coming into the roleplay itself so
I think we did a decent job.
We'll have to wait and
see what the results.
>> I think we were a great team.
>> Understanding,
you've got people here with agendas and
dynamics that are going on.
How to facilitate a closing process and
that is really important.
>> We had a great time.
We did not succeed In achieving our goal,
but
I think that there was a lot
of learning in the failure.
>> The other day, everybody,
we're all still people and
we still gotta work together, right?
So to me, that's what I focused on, I care
less about the data but how they dealt
with each other, and dealt with us as
advisors is what I was looking for.
>> I think we have some preconceived
notions, at least from the case,
about what certain personalities
would be like, and we prepared for
those personalities and then they didn't
let those things show through, really,
in their personality so it ended up,
we had to be a little bit more dynamic
emotionally than we expected to.
>> These guys are very good.
They're at a maturity
level that's great so
you get a lot of the same kind of
interaction you would with a real company.
But like anybody else, I think it's
fun to see how quickly you can
accelerate their ability to pick up
what goes on in a meeting like this.
>> To be honest I wish I had had this
opportunity in going through my career,
and we kind of had to learn it by doing.
>> Squad 55.
>> Squad 55
>> One, two, three, 52.
[MUSIC]